si vous partiez on va voir si elodie
laurent des propriétaires victimes de
squatters on va revenir sur toute
l'histoire histoire et d'hengelo dit
laurent on va reprendre l'histoire
depuis le début ou travaillé dur pour
mettre l'argent de côté vous d'acheter
une maison depuis combien de temps vous
économisez tous les deux ça fait deux
ans deux ans au moins voilà pour avoir
déjà un petit pécule pour pouvoir avoir
un crédit au pays un crédit oui bien sûr
sur la maison dont vous payez un crédit
pour que d'autres apprentis en profite
ce que ça vous décidez d'acheter un bien
visiter cette maison voilà donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe visiter la maison
vous aimez bien la maison tout va bien
c'est ça on hésite la maison en
septembre dernier d'accord on est en
tirant plusieurs fois en visite on
on kiffe mais mon kiff la maison est
vide complètement vide il ya un matelas
au sol d'accord voilà je la visite
plusieurs fois tout va bien jusque là
tout va bien d'accord donc là vous
vous décidez d'acheter la maison fait
une offre l'offre est acceptée vous
faites un crédit et vous vous avez la
maison à disposition à partir de quand
oui donc c'est ça on avait eu les clés
quand vous avez les clés quand je la
signe un jour de vacances
le 19 mai d'accord donc c'était était
dernièrement il n'y a même pas un mois
là vous avez les clés qu'est ce qui se
passe vous vous rendez dans la maison
ça donc là qu'est ce qui se passe on y
va tout de suite bien sûr bah oui normal
vous avez envie et vue oui j'avais des
copains qui étaient avec moi on avait
prévu de faire un barbecue pour fêter ça
on se rend là-bas y voilà on trouve on
trouve la maison comme ça la voiture les
rideaux un chien
les vélos des patinettes
donc lâché
sur tech c'est normal ben voila je
demande un petit peu à jouve le
portillon je rentre je vais choquer je
demande de mon explication que bonjour
et que vous tombez sur qui je tombe sur
un enfant je demande à avoir un des
parrains
il est sorti et on s'est expliqués m'a
dit qu'il avait acheté cette maison
le monsieur vous a dit qu'il avait
acheté c'est ça il a acheté la maison
donc là je comprends pas j'ai moi aussi
je les achetais voilà j'ai des papiers
je comprends pas et
et de là je demande de présenter des
papiers me montre ils montrent une
promesse de vente une promesse de vente
estimé ça c'est pas ça fait pas je sais
rien une promesse de vente voilà je suis
comment vous l'avez payé bah je vais
payer 120 mille euros en espèces
et je tombe par terre j'ai dit mais on
n'achète pas une maison sur un point
table c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
il ya un acte de chez le notaire et
quelque chose et de là je vois que hélas
il n'a pas tout ça mais mais il me dit
ap ap les gendarmes ils sont au courant
c'est chez moi voilà donc chose que j'ai
fait j'ai appelé les gendarmes d'accord
et ils m'ont confirmé que j'étais bien
le propriétaire mais que de là il s
engager une longue procédure parce qu'il
était il était finalement chez lui lors
de fouilles
je suis
dans l'appartement alors laissons 6,6
donc aller ils sont trois enfants et
quatre aux quatre enfants et autres
enfants et deux adultes d'accord plus le
chien donc là
qu'est ce que vous vous dites tous les
titres incendie dans une histoire
incroyable c'est incroyable ce qui se
passe
j'ai les gendarmes ont fini par nous
dire gentiment de partir d'accords ah
oui de partir de chez vous à ouides par
serena et la loi évolue et monsieur
madame étant ici se donne donc donc là
vous êtes là bas d'appeler les gendarmes
ils arrivent dit non mais c'est votre
maison oui mais c'est lui qui doit
habiter d'abord parce que pour l'instant
il ok si c'est parce que ça faisait
combien temps qu'il était dans la maison
je pensais ça faisait quand même temps
qu'il était depuis novembre
novembre demande moi ce que moi la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est quand vous avez visité la maison
où il avait visité combien de fois deux
fois trois fois trois fois renfort fois
avec l'agent immobilier n'était pas au
courant de ça
non non mais apparemment la maison avait
déjà été squattés d'accord auparavant la
dc à la déjà été squattés mais nous
quand la visite et avait un matelas par
terre il n'y avait pas de mobilier il y
avait pas de freewest et des bas des
caleçons et chaussettes avait rien s'il
y avait quelqu'un qui était installée
rougissent et peut-être des jeunes ni
danses d'antan il se pose là je sais pas
il est donc et vous avez essayé d'en
parler avec l'agent immobilier s'il est
au courant de ça ou pas du tout non
parce que le prix le prix était
intéressant on a voulu en a voulu nous
accélérer un petit peu limite pour pour
acheter on n'a pas trop voulu ébruiter
que le prix était à nous ça ne convenait
l'avez vous l'avez trouvé comment la
maison vous avez une connaissance qui
nous a ramené d'accord d'accord vous
harnais mais voilà donc et c'est vrai
que la maison était plus basse et est un
prix beaucoup plus bas que ce qui est
aux alentours de l'est le même genre de
maison c'était vraiment une bonne
affaire c'était une bonne affaire la
demande vient après ya beaucoup de
travaux dont cameron a fait le
propriétaire à mon avis l'ancien
propriétaire est au courant que la
maison était squatté voilà où qualité
sous lens côté ou qu'elle était déjà
squatté et c'est tellement une galère je
vais la vendre et je vais la mettre à un
prix beaucoup plus bas pour pouvoir
voilà trouver un acheteur assez vite et
l'acheteur qui a
été fait et c était vous de elodie et
laurent donc là vous êtes avec la
gendarmerie pour pour partait donc chez
vous vous faites quoi j'ai fait mon
barbecue ouais chez moi comme ça pour
quoi j'avais acheté la viande j'avais
j'aime à rouiba ça je me suis fait un
barbecue chez moi et moi vous vous
perdez pas leur en ai vraiment marre de
tout quand même si ça devait faire un
barbecue
vous faites le barbecue d'accord à la et
quelques jours après certes on m'a bien
sûr j'y retourne je dis aller tout seul
dès maintenant avec des copains d'accord
parce que j'aurai vrai copain voilà j'ai
toujours essayé de m'intimider un petit
peu on va essayer de l'essayer de chez
pas discuter essayer de faire quelque
chose je peux pouvait pas rester comme
ça bien sûr ça on fout donc cessons a
aussi voulu jouer des lois essayer de
nous rentrer et en fait on s'est dit
qu'une fois nous on allait être entré
peut-être qu'ils n'allaient pas pouvoir
nous sortir et s'étonner qu'on est les
vrais propriétaires essayer ça vous avez
essayé d'y aller quand de gaieté quand
il ya des personnes à la maison n'ont
même pas qu'on était là ah oui rentrée
je me suis dit je vais escalader malgré
le chien malgré
qu'ils soient là et je voudrais le
portillon et puis on va se mettre dedans
map les gendarmes on va dire pas comment
on fait du coup là alors venez je suis
propriétaire il est vraiment il est chez
lui aussi vous allez vivre etc leader
vous avez fait vous avez si vous avez
fait ça on l'a fait alors à nous on
vient et nous non
c'est rigole c'est dégagé
loin sa loi la loi
le roumois moi c'est cette genre de truc
qui me rend fou je deviendrais fou je
vous dis la vérité c'est un quad donc
labourot rentrez chez vous en fait un
barbecue et
pas de barbecue pour rentrer chez eux
mais bouchard on nous dit vous dites là
faire elle va jamais se terminera pour
moi c'était c'était fini c'était fini
c'est si ce n'est pas vous êtes 10 kwh
alors à ce moment là bas qu'on allait en
avoir pour des années en plus vous payez
vous alliez payer crédit de la maison
même si vous aviez votre ancienne
habitation était en location on est
toujours en location était toujours au
sommet vous êtes toujours l'occasion
donc là vous payez des deux classes et
c'est là c'est l'enfer une fois dans la
vie mère l'a fait quoi dans l'année
actuellement je suis sans emploi
et vos mélodies je travaille dans un
laboratoire
d'accord mais c'est donc c'est c1 c'est
un cauchemar donc là ensuite qu'est ce
que vous faites vous y allez avec vos
potes comme vous m'avez dit qu'est-ce
qui se passe bah ouais donc l'harmonie a
été on sert fait virer vous sonnez quand
vous sautez ou du temps non la gvh n'est
plus un chien d'accord d'escaladé vous
allez rire avec vos potes et la coupable
voyez qui affaire de famille le nom la
femme en premier d'accord vous lisez pas
là là elle a appelé la dit qu'on était
1 un petit peu nombreux du coup ils ont
ramené aussi des copains
parisiens c'est des copains mais bon il
n'y a pas eu de il n'y a pas eu trop de
soucis ça va chauffer un petit peu mais
rien en soi rien et on a fini par être
viré aussi on est rentré vous ont dit qu
à vous a dit c'est chez nous on bouge
pas dit c'est chez nous on bouge pas
quoi cc c'est donc y'a rien à faire on
bougera pas d'ici on bougera pas fais ce
que tu veux monde descend je suis chez
moi et m'a dit d'accord voilà donc de là
on parle un petit peu avec l'inde a
rebondi mais comment on va pouvoir
régler cette histoire la commission
comment que ça va se finir parce qu'au
bout d'un moment il va falloir faire
quelque chose venez déposer une main
courante
alors mais une main courante on fait
quoi que la main courante bon on a
déposé une main courante on a fait
constater un huissier a vu ses revenus
et la constructi l'a constaté quoi il
est venu où il est des plus rentrer dans
la vie d'un peuple non il est venu à
l'extérieur d'accord il ya extérieur il
a fait quoi constat qui vient ils
n'essayaient pas de parler avec les gens
et voilà ils écoutent ce qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'ils avaient à leur dire et voilà
après il rédige un rapport qui nous a
transmis et kiki et il nous a dit qu'il
allait engager une procédure
de là il me dit il faut aller porter
plainte la main à la main la rencontre
ne suffit pas il faut aller porter
plainte je vers la gendarmerie j'essaie
de porter plainte ils veulent pas
prendre notre place
pourquoi ils veulent pas prendre notre
plainte parce qu'il serait arrivé avant
que ce soit neutre notre domicile oh
[ __ ] voient donc leurs 19 quand je
suis arrivé c'était déjà là donc ça
signifie que lorsque j'étais en train de
signer était déjà là donc avant que ce
soit vraiment chez moi il était déjà là
donc ils vous disent ils vous disent
quoi il ne faut pas prendre votre main
ne peut pas apprendre votre plainte
alors on fait quoi a c'est ce que je
leur demandais qu'est ce qu'on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment que ça va
se tourner contre qui alors dans ce cas
là faut qu'on a un avocat et est passé
par le des frais d'avocats payés à
loyers la dgac
crédit plus l'avocat
à la fin c'est toi qui te retrouve à la
rue qui va l'exploiter en fait c'est
énorme et ça mais c'est ça et donc là il
vous est donc là ils vous disent d'aller
voir un avocat vous avez fait quoi non
je n'ai pas été voir l'avocat j'ai plus
je parle avec l'huissier je me suis
renseigné un petit peu
et j'ai contacté les médias c'est bien
fait j'ai bien fait bien sûr vous avez
contacté les médias vous êtes dit c'est
la dernière chance pour m'aider à 17h
lens parce que sinon médias cette
affaire c'est si incroyable alors juste
on va revenir et le président raconte t
il à la fin de l'histoire dans un
instant vous dit que vous l'avez acheté
140000 euros et eux ce qui chapote ils
disent qu'ils ont payé 120 millions
nécessaires c'est ça en fait est ce que
cette histoire est vraie ou est ce
qu'ils ont acheté la maison pas du tout
que jamais je pense pas qu'il aurait
acheté
la personne qui loue racheter ont pas
une personne qui est la maison n'a
jamais appartenu peut-être un autre
squat heures en fait peut-être un autre
scooter il aura faim
l'histoire c'est qu'il y
avait quelque chose aux nerfs 1000 euros
espèce river
120000 euros en espèces et gendarmes il
aurait dit aux mecs c'est qui le gars
qui tape
c'est du bluff c'est du marché du lait
ont plutôt
trouvé à qui les ont longtemps acquis
les gilles verdez des sommes
donc là là donc là il ya bien il ya un
autre truc s'il ya quelqu'un qui nous
demandent aussi sur les réseaux juste
sheridan dame qui m'accuse je ne
comprends pas l'état des lieux n'a pas
été fait avant la signature triste
vraiment j'espère qu'ils retrouveront
vite leurs maisons mais l'état des lieux
c'est vrai il a été fait ou pas
sais tu fais maintenant tu en es tu fait
l'état des lieux mais entre le moment où
tu visites et le notaire il ya les trois
mois il ya toujours les deux mois trois
mois il suffit qu'il arrive jusqu'à 48
heures avant qu'ils aillent chez leur s
est terminée rideau tu n'as pas ta
maison toi tu crois tu es venu il ya
deux jours tu es passé devant et que ta
voiture tu regardes chéri et si on va
mettre ça et si on va faire ça tu as
chez le notaire s'était passé tu viens
plusieurs fois à voir la maison là je
vais faire des travaux je vais changer
la clôture mais quand tu vas chez le
notaire où ils sont déjà rentrés alors
ça qui est dans les clous le squatteur
vous a proposé 5 millions
en espèces c'est ça non c'est pas ça
c'est y demande allemande 5000 euros
pour partir
la réponse à une maison qu'il a achetée
sans la
mémoire
non mais donc il vous a demandé 5000
euros pour partir et ça tout à l'heure
il m'a demandé
à maintenir il a été au rendez vous avec
le maire ouais il est vrai que les
religions à des mots est le maire et en
revenant de chez le maire je
l'interprète j'ai alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe voilà vous avez partir oui c'est
bon j'ai compris je me suis fait
arnaquer j'ai des faux papiers et elle a
même fait comprendre il me
sidy bâ
dit dans un mois je m'en vais cinq ans
il ya même un délai 25 nice s'est
incliné un mois c'est même pas eu à
intervenir mais c'est un mois
mais en fait c'est pas du tout faire
nakisa nitoo ouais bien sûr celle ci le
papier qu'il a c'est à l'ordinateur n'y
a pas d'entente est assurée rien il a 3
po feuille chiffonnée il a été voir le
meilleur le maire locaux des signes il
nous connaît le maroc au rang de la
sphère oui il lui a dit il le dit quoi
le maire
je sais pas trop ce qui se sent le vent
toujours très ce que nous on a été voir
le maire également d'un combat bien sûr
mais qu'est ce qui vous a dit une mère
qui soutenait mais qu'on soit il savait
pas réellement quoi faire lui dans cette
situation qui ne pouvait pas intervenir
directement sur ça c'est la préfecture
carrément un moment où vous avez pensé à
aller sortir manier les inférences est
compliqué il ya des 1ers non m enfants
non mais la question est simple d'accord
moi j'ai pensé oui ou non bah oui normal
mais forcément du monde vous avez pensé
quoi vous a dit on va les sortir je
voulais sortir je vais venir et puis au
lieu de le discuter je vais leur a joué
les invités à sortir
et ça ça aurait été une mauvaise
solution
la difficulté c'est que ça n'était pas
votre domicile vous êtes propriétaire du
bien certes mais c'est pas votre
domicile aux termes de la loi un
domicile c'est un andalou on habite
réellement c'est à dire avec des meubles
avec du linge etc et ont allaité c'est
pas votre domicile alors que lui 6 aussi
incroyable que ça puisse paraître les
100 titres donc d'où
la réponse des gendarmes je leur réponds
c'est possible oui mais la réponse des
gens dans lequel tout à fait légitime
est-ce qu'elle eût déjà des cas il faut
que moi je vous dis il faut pas du tout
de faire les doléances j'ai pas ce qui a
eu déjà des cas où la dame est sur lui
les ont sortis et qu'après bon moi c'est
ça c'est pas vrai ski puisqu'elle est le
squatteur pour aller porter plainte a
déclaré je suis en retraite maintenant
je peux le dire je les fais un d'accord
[Applaudissements]
fonction pourrait y aura plus donc a
longtemps ça va être vraiment oui parce
que quand même la mauvaise foi bien sûr
qu'on a une tête de canard des potes de
canard cependant un canard racontez nous
comment qu'est ce qui s'est passé a
raconté nous parce que vous avez des cas
désespérés je vous le dit tout à l'heure
ça fait quand même éliminé avec un cas
désespéré et désespérant et puis il ya
des escrocs patentés de ça il ya des
gens il vous sort défaut bain à un bail
vous le prenez dans une librairie vous
allez prendre le médecin mais c'est ça
la main vous dites que c'est un gage d
paye en liquide et cetera comme cette
histoire cent vingt mille euros et ça
tient pas la route quoi donc il arrive
un moment où
derrière le policier y aussi un coeur
énorme et obligations du bord des
conneries
non non non
[Musique]
les endroits un peu particulier un peu
chaud mais vous voyez que la
désespérance elle est des deux côtés il
faut savoir faut savoir peser le pour et
le contre et les choses près c'est très
bien quand on a de l'autorité et qu'on
sait
on sait s'y prendre sa part dans tous
les sens interdits par laser exactement
et je vous lis tous ceux qui n'ont rien
ceux qui ont
si il se trouve que voilà il ya des
squatters si vous ne le faites pas parce
que là ça sera encore plus un drame
avions si vous prenez trois ans de
prison orages 30000 euros d'amendé là ça
serait la lecture d'un conducteur dans
les 48 heures quand vous êtes en
flagrant délit y'a pas de problème
d'accord voilà prévenus la prévenue la
police ou les gendarmes et gendarmes si
effectivement ça s'est passé dans les 48
heures ils interviendront au delà des 48
heures et n'interviendront pas il ya un
nom de liste des tons va on va où
maintenant c'est que l'afer a avancé
aujourd'hui
donc là c'était quand vous décidez de
contacter les médias quand
tecan
semaine dernière vous contacter le
parisien c'est ça le parisien
aujourd'hui en france le parisien
d'accord vous leur dites quoi vous le
racontez votre histoire voilà je laisse
mes coordonnées me rappelle je réponds
de l'histoire émeut diba l'histoire
m'intéresse c'est ce que je peux venir
on va faire un petit article le détenu a
fait un article derrière j'ai été
contacté de nouveau par le parisien met
pas au service vidéo d'accord on dit ça
nous intéresse on va faire un petit
reportage hélas hélas là ça a explosé
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ensuite
j'ai été contacté par tous les médias
hélas là ce soir il ya eu un tweet du
ministre de l'intérieur non gérald
darmanin qui vient de dire cette
situation est inacceptable
avec donc nous demandons immédiatement
avec le voilà immédiatement au préfet 91
d'engager la procédure de l'article 38
de la loi dalo pour une évacuation
rapide des occupants illégaux dont kiel
il appartient à 38 ce qu'est ce c'est un
fait ça c'est la dernière loin
[Applaudissements]
réquisition du préfet le préfet a
obligation d'intervenir d'un
immédiatement un il donne le préfet va
adresser une obligation de partir une
mise en demeure de partir et la personne
à 48 heures pas d'accord si dans les 48
heures il n'a pas
il n'a pas dégagé le préfet peut
intervenir à tout moment alors il ya des
cas où le préfet va moduler un petit peu
d'attiser que là mon ami voilà par
contre là je pense que la démarche était
bon on a un prévenu
donc là ils vont ils vont recevoir quand
le demain à mon avis demain ou après
demain le prochain auxerre ce week-end
ils pourront mettre dans leur maison
j'espère pour eux j'espère pour eux a
priori c'est pourquoi qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer ce qui pourrait se
passer et bien exactement l inverse de
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est à dire que la
famille qu'est la doua sur place avec
quatre ou cinq ans fonde pas ce que j'ai
compris ça alertent les associations
deux mondes l'intervention de certains
médias faisant passer pour des
malheureux et vous allez voir la
situation va se retourner moi je trouve
ce ce tweet la très courageux mais
méfiance il faut savoir que iliad et il
ya des gens non c'est je veux dire
presque le métier d étonner il failli
tourner tout ça donc de la branche
prudence prudence parce que c'est vous
pouvez quatre enfants ça peut être ils
sont tous à dire il ya un délai aller à
l'issue de la mise en demeure du préfet
on a deux mois pour un pur pour demander
à faire annuler la décision du préfet
auprès du tribunal administratif de
lille peuvent très bien le demander mais
est-ce que je vous dise que j'ai peur
c'est ça on est on est dans un monde de
tellement de mensonges de manipulations
et c'est qu'on peut très bien avoir
demain une association qui sienne qui
viennent demain devant le la maison
s'enchaîner en disant vous voulez vous
les exploitants parce qu'à quatre
enfants et un chien je prends plus donc
voilà je demande à voir elle demande à
voir c'est complexe vous avez bien
compris que c'est complexe parce que on
joue sur une sur sur les sentiments sur
l'émotion etc mais ça peut aller dans
les deux sens bien sûr si cet après midi
à une émission de télévision où aller
quatre enfants dans la misère sans
culottes et c'est
l'opinion change du tout aussi
intéressante
c'est intéressant ce que dit mon rythme
et là c'est jugé qu il a un charme il a
donc là ils ont 48 heures ce qu'ils
peuvent faire appel ou est ce qui peut
venir le firent appel là c'est suspens
si donc la ffr prévenu stricte quatre
sinistres hâtif mais le dressage et va
durer combien de temps ça peut aller
vite dans un cas comme ça la tribune
administratif va très vite français dans
ses conclusions donc si les conclusions
sont bonnes ça la région le pire il faut
48 heures ils font appel et semaine
prochaine voilà donc lundi le préfet dit
c'est bon ils doivent partir qu'est ce
qui se passe donc les autorités peuvent
venir les sortir de l'eau a fait ces
jours du matin les gendarmes ils
viennent et vise maintenant faut partir
quoi d'accord alors généralement on
vient avec des déménageurs pour emmener
tous les meubles qui a et les mettre
chez garderen dans un box 505 mais je
vous dis je vous alerte
on peut très bien avoir un retour de
manuel fouette x 2 x 2 prudents alors
encore twitter hier 20 minutes il ya dix
huit suite à notre instruction un arrêté
de mise en demeure a été pris ce jeudi
donc c'est très large audit donc voilà
par le préfet 80 ans afin d'expulser la
famille des squatters cette situation
inacceptable à prendre fin et les
véritables propriétaires vont pouvoir
retrouver leurs maisons donc ça c'était
donc la cible 48 heures donc si tout se
passe bien normalement voilà sa demande
lundi vous êtes dans la maison
assurément après vous dites vous ça le
jour de rebondir et ça qu'est ce qu'il
fait là le ministre de l'intérieur il
fait quoi dans un cas comme ça vous
savez
c'est très bien d'avoir fait ce que vous
avez fait c'était la meilleure est la
meilleure solution souvenons nous de ces
retraités qui avait récupéré leur
logement c'est exactement ils ont fait
la même démarche mais je vous dis
méfions-nous enfin je voudrais pas qu'on
va falloir dans le monde pas donner de
noms
j'ai vu des cas j'ai vu des cas vraiment
était flagrante mais là moi moi là
dessus c'est tellement médiatisé je
pense que le premier mérite est
tellement pur pour laurent elodie que je
déconseille à ceux qui
voilà qui volent voilà encore se mettent
à travers des associations non c'est le
quotidien ouais mais bon oui mais là là
là c'est franchement c'est indéfendable
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de
vous y croyez maintenant laurent et audi
vous move n'y croyez vous dites encore
ça va être encore eu autant que vous
n'êtes pas dedans vous n'y croyez pas
tant que je suis pas dedans j'y crois
pas moi vraiment là pour l'instant je
suis très content de ce qu'a fait
monsieur le ministre oui mais mais tant
que je suis pas dedans pour moi ce sera
fini quand vous dites nous allons tenir
hier on vient de le dire il ya des
recours il ya des voilà maintenant que
je suis là dedans ça donne de l'espoir
bien sûr bien sûr la sphère alalalala
prêt à l'avancé
incroyablement est donc là vous allez
attendre quoique avec 48 heures sur le
papier ses marques et même 24 heures ils
sont invités à quitter les lieux dans 24
heures il ya à l'heure c'est 17h05
aujourd'hui donc dès demain 17h05 ils
sont censées avoir quitté les lieux
allez vous tenir au courant quand même
devant donc la domann 17h05 vous êtes
enceinte 17h06 et un barbecue
on n'a rien quarante huit heures pour
expulser mais pas dans les premières 24
heures adacore gars qu'on laisse ses
premières 24 heures à la personne pour
pour partir d'accords donc c'est savoir
à propos de m et sinon ces 48 heures
mais oui gilles pas commis a quatre
enfants scolarisés il va falloir que la
poursuite des études scolaires soit
assurée et comme il ya quatre enfants il
va falloir au moment de l'expulsion ou
juste après qu'ils aient un rôle
logement de la famille assurée par les
autorités le délai il est parfait
j'espère pour vous c'est pas tout à fait
aussi simple que ça ça peut prendre un
peu plus de temps incroyable défi grâce
aux tweets de darmanin et grâce à la
médiatisation j'espère vraiment pour
vous que ce week-end vous serez dans
votre maison non je la leur barbecue
pourquoi pas si vous avez des
végétariens je viens
juste en fait à toutes les personnes qui
sont dans ce cas là et qui n'ont pas eu
l'opportunité de médiatiser en fait donc
il faudrait que monsieur le ministre en
regardant ça ne se lit les techniques
n'est au courant tous les cas il agit
très vite hein t'as pas tous les cas qui
lui remonte là il a agi très
bon l'an parlant de ce cas là ce qu'il
faut et qu'il faut traiter c'est la base
qui prépare en tout cas surtout la loi
c'est la loi il est féministe de la
justice radar management partout non
plus c'est vrai voilà l'idée ministre de
l'intérieur pour l'instant voilà il
s'est beaucoup due to value de l'année
locatif quand même à tout ça bien sûr et
ça c'est beaucoup de la compétence du
préfet donc d'un administratif donc là
on rappelle demain 24 heures normalement
il doit partir à
17h05 mais ils peuvent rester en fait
ils peuvent et construisez que 48 heures
après donc ce serait voilà ce serait
donc samedi à 17h05 si il ne pas pas
samedi la toile est exposée mais comme a
dit voilà il faudrait pas que voilà
l'opinion publique de chant retourne se
retourne et que ça fasse un trouble à
l'ordre public et dans ces cas là le
préfet pourrait surseoir il est obligé
de deux d'entériner la décision du
ministre sauf s'il ya trouble à l'ordre
public et le fait que des enfants soient
dans la nature peut être un trouble à
l'ordre public clément moi je suis
demandé 5000 euros déjà
bien sûr ça y est
il a su que le ministre bien sûr parce
qu'il a sur ces sujets et vous a dit moi
on va vous donner 5 millions il a du mal
à le maire a dû lui dire tu as sont là
ça y est elle née milliard de gens mais
c'est perdu ses paniers vous allez
sortir yahia il ya une loi qui fait qu'
ils peuvent vous sortir donc essayé je
lui proposais 5000 euros au moins que je
prenne cinq mille ans avant de partir
mais le truc c'est que là je ne vois pas
comment l'opinion publique pourrait se
retourner après la proposition de 5000
euros dans mal
voilà donc là avant sa vie enfin
j'espère que ça devrait aller vraiment
cessé en plus j'ai à présent vous
discuté beaucoup avec lui bages et
celles dont vous êtes resté vachement
pour toi j'ai l'impression à huy avait
vraiment vraiment moi on m'a vivement
conseillé de rester coi est gentil ouais
c'est donc c'est ce que j'ai fait et
éloignez vous vous en vous en pour vous
n'en pouvez plus vous voulez vous avant
tu subiras laurent il faut il faut les
sortir on n'en peut plus la whey où j'ai
pu essayer de le raisonner par oui c'est
ça oui de lui-même il les aurait
peut-être sorti en mai
mais oui forcément enfin ça fait ont
depuis le 19 mai on pense qu'à ça on
ressasse on imagine les plombs les plus
improbables pour essayer de récupérer
les lieux après batou dit aussi de bac
ça peut se retourner contre nous donc on
fait tout pour mais ouais c'est elle et
dans quel état la maison là à lhassa
voilà ça pour l'instant ça va à peu près
bon s'est il ya des rats et des rats qui
sont arrivés c'est ça le bar garder les
voilà rivaux coupe était un partant on a
vu dès aujourd'hui vous avez vu d'hier à
aujourd'hui c'est vrai parfois est donc
là un manager il puisse y avoir encore
un travail et puis à la base la maison
est pas un enfin il pas aux normes
surtout que ce soit y la plomberie
l'électricité il ya encore de l'amiante
au niveau du sous-sol enfin vous avez
des enfants à la base et un nom à vous
d'accord donc là vous allez mettre la
maison decker si vous pouvez la
retrouver et évacuer les rares donc la
même si vous y allez bon c'est du boulot
koirala ya du boulot ballet du boulot
ouais bon si je reprends processionné le
savez quand vous allez faire parce que
vous êtes encore en location donc là
vous allez aller direct à la maison si
demain voilà 17h05 qui sont partis là
vous êtes dans la maison où j'ai vu
immédiatement je bouge plus même s'il ya
des rares on va dormir ensemble
on m'a très bien souhaitant tout cas
vous nous tenez au courant demain on
vous dit comment ça s'est passé est
vraiment faut que j'espère que voilà il
faut j'espère qu'il aura pas de
mauvaises surprises et que ça à pouvoir
le faire et l'oni l'on mettra au
barbecue avec plaisir de nous écouter
avec plaisir que j'adore la merguez
voilà merci